uns jetzt zugeschaltet
bundesaußenminister heiko maas guten
abend herr maas als allererste natürlich
die frage wie geht es ihnen momentan wie
geht s gut vielen dank der nachfrage die
charaktere ist ja auch nur eine
vorsichtsmaßnahme wenn man jemanden über
den weg gelaufen ist
der positiv getestet wurde und so ist es
bei mir gewesen ich bin auch schon
getestet wurden aber negativ also
insofern alles in ordnung
emmas erklären sie uns mal wo sie da
jetzt sitzen das sieht ja eigentlich
alles sehr professionell aus man sieht
dort flaggen aber wir wissen sie sind
sozusagen wieder in das haus ihrer
lebenspartnerin in brandenburg
geflüchtet wie muss man sich das
vorstellen wie leben sie da jetzt
alleine wird es aber charakterlich
anders geht aber da ich vom letzten wahl
schon gewisse erfahrung haben wir uns
ein paar sachen mitgenommen die ich mir
hier im wohnzimmer aufgestellt wird dann
wird es ein bisschen offizielle aussieht
weil man den ganzen tag telefoniert und
den ganzen tag videokonferenzen macht
und so ist das halt in corona zeiten
aber das wird jetzt auch noch vorbei
und wie muss man sich das vorstellen als
bundesaußenminister wie werden sie jetzt
versorgt werden dann da lebensmittel vor
die tür gestellt oder wie läuft das ab
bei ihnen geht nicht weil ich mich
selbst isolieren muss gibt es
tatsächlich nette menschen die alle zwei
tage
mir war es vor die tür stellen und so
versorge ich mich selber geht auch von
dort wo sie jetzt sind in der quarantäne
in brandenburg verfolgen sie natürlich
was in den usa passiert sind sie da mit
allen technischen möglichkeiten
ausgestattet in brandenburg gibt es ja
manchmal auch nicht so richtig guten
empfang aber wir sehen das funktioniert
jetzt gerade ganz gut konnten sie die
pressekonferenz verfolgen die richard
greene l dort gehalten hat in dem wada
wo er gesagt hat das es hinweise darauf
gibt dass dort eben manchmal
manipulationen begangen worden sein soll
also dass menschen nicht wählen konnten
er sagte auch dass möglicherweise tote
dort gewählt haben wie bewerten sie
diese vorwürfe aus dem trump lager ich
hab das
nicht gesehen aber ich weiß natürlich
auch gelesen ich kann das nicht
beurteilen ich weiß nicht welche
vorgänge ist da gibt oder auf welche
bezug genommen wird es gibt ja auch
internationale wahlbeobachter in den
vereinigten staaten auch aus deutschland
da sind deutsche bundestagsabgeordnete
dort die sich heute zu wort gemeldet
haben und die zumindest berichtet haben
dort wo sie gewesen sind ist nichts
aufgefallen was in irgendeiner weise
gegen die regeln verstoßen würde
aber sicherlich wäre vorwürfe erhebt
muss hier auch beweisen und wenn die
beweise ernsthaft sind dann ist das
alles zu überprüfen
jetzt hat der us präsident donald trump
gerade getwittert stoppte das zählen
hört auf mit dem zählen wie ist das zu
bewerten aus ihrer sicht
na ja das ist schon ein bisschen
erstaunlich also wenn eine wahl
ausgezählt wird und die stimmen die
eingegangen sind egal ob sie persönlich
abgegeben worden sind im wahllokal oder
per brief an das kennen wir ja auch
alles als dort aus deutschland natürlich
müssen diese stimmen ausgezählt werden
und man kann nicht einfach die
auszählung beenden bevor alle stimmen
dann auch gewertet worden sind also das
ist schon ein etwas erstaunlicher
vorgang wichtig in einer demokratie ist
dass man sich an die regeln hält auch
bei wahlen und natürlich muss das auch
alles überprüft werden aber natürlich
die grundlage ist mal dass alle stimmen
ausgezählt werden und wenn man dann sagt
jetzt muss man aufgehört werden weil das
ergebnis gerade so schön ist für einen
dann ist das von hier aus nur sehr sehr
schwer nachvollziehbar
jetzt gerade herrscht natürlich für
unsicherheit in amerika weil dieses
wahlergebnis so lange auf sich warten
lässt aber selbst wenn es fest steht
weiß man noch immer nicht wie die
reaktion aus dem jeweils verliererteam
muss man so sagen dann sind was bedeutet
dass auch für die weltpolitik und
außenpolitik der usa
wenn es jetzt eine längere zeit der
unsicherheit dort gibt es ist natürlich
nicht schön
die vereinigten staaten werden gebraucht
es gibt so viele internationale krisen
und konflikte die ohne mithilfe der
vereinigten staaten nicht gelöst werden
können
insofern hoffen wir dass das natürlich
jetzt alles so schnell wie möglich unter
dach und fach kommt dass es ein ergebnis
gibt wobei man auch mal dazu sagen muss
die ergebnisse sind ja so klar das ist
teilweise gar nicht anders zu erwarten
ist dass da auch noch einmal nach
zählungen stattfinden das ist kein so
unüblicher vorgang das gibt es auch bei
uns bei weil die ganz knapp sind das
noch einmal nachgezählt wird aber
wünschenswert wäre natürlich schon dass
dann irgendwann auch das ergebnis der
nach zählungen anerkannt wird dass es
vor allen dingen gegen jähnigen der es
nicht geschafft hat dass er ein guter
demokrat ist und dann auch eine
niederlage anerkennt so sind nun einmal
die spielregeln in der demokratie und
ich glaube gerade in den vereinigten
staaten
da gucken ganz viele hin
international wie man mit einer solchen
situation umgeht und deshalb glaube ich
wäre es für die vereinigten staaten
selbst am besten wenn das ergebnis so
schnell wie möglich feststellt wo
möglicherweise auch noch mal einzelne
wahllokale in einzelnen wahllokalen
nachgezählt wird aber dass dann
irgendwann auch mal gut ist und dass wir
wissen wer dieses land regiert
denn dieses land ist international
außerordentlich wichtig und wird
gebraucht wenn sie jetzt die letzten
drei tage einmal revue passieren lassen
ich habe gerade schon gesagt das ist so
ein bisschen wie täglich grüßt das
murmeltier auch bei uns hier im oval
office wie auch dachten sie schon jetzt
wird's trump und es wird beiden wie oft
ging es hin und her dachten sie manchmal
die wahl sei schon entschieden und dann
wieder doch nicht also was die erste
überraschung ist natürlich die gewesen
dass mal wieder die meisten prognosen
danebengelegen haben also es gibt keinen
erdrutsch sieg auch nicht im kongress
auch im senat hat sich das
mehrheitsverhältnis wahrscheinlich nicht
verändert also das ist erst mal viel
viel knapper geworden und ich glaube da
hat man sehr schnell dann auch erwarten
können dass das eine wahrscheinlich doch
längere angelegenheit wird weil das
natürlich wichtig ist dass die regeln
alle beachtet werden und dass der
präsident der gewählt wird auch die
notwendige legitimation and sein amt
mitbringen kann denn eines muss man ja
mal sehen
dieses land ist so polarisiert durch
diesen wahlkampf aber auch durch vieles
was davor geschehen ist ist die
wichtigste aufgabe wahrscheinlich des
amerikanischen präsident sein wird
zunächst einmal sein land und die
gesellschaft der vereinigten staaten
wieder zusammenzubringen und insofern
knappe wahlergebnis gibt es immer in der
demokratie
deshalb ist es wichtig dass das alles
sehr sehr ordnungsgemäß über die bühne
geht
aber wichtig ist genau so dass
diejenigen die die wahl verlieren dass
auch anerkennen und gute verlierer sind
heraus minister alle welt schaut jetzt
sozusagen auf diese magische zahl 270
und die frage ob joe biden oder dann
doch donald trump das erreichen kann
momentan hat offenbar joe biden bessere
chancen wie ist das für sie jetzt dort
in der quarantäne was passiert werden
diese zahl erreicht wird wie viele
telefone klingeln
bei ihnen oder klopft jemand an der tür
was machen sie dann rufen sie dann den
gewinner direkt an oder versuchen ihn zu
erreichen wie muss man sich das
vorstellen also an der tür kopf glaubt
keiner heißt dafür keiner hier
reinkommen so lang in quarantäne bin
aber ich habe auch heute in den ganzen
tag telefoniert mit vielen kollegen
international wir gucken alle auch das
wahlergebnis es ist aber auch nicht so
dass wir nicht vorbereitet sind das
heißt wenn diese beinahe abgeschlossen
sind werden wir selber aber auch die
europäische union wir im übrigen in
enger abstimmung mit den mit unseren
freunden in frankreich der neuen
administration egal ob neuer oder alter
präsident vorschläge machen wie nach
unserer auffassung das transatlantische
verhältnis wieder auf kurs gebracht
werden kann denn da gibt es wirklich
einiges was wir aufarbeiten müssen es
gibt aber auch so viele themen in denen
wir die gleichen interessen haben wir
haben die gleichen werte die vereinigten
staaten sind für uns der wichtigste
partner außerhalb der europäischen union
und deshalb wir werden viele krisen und
konflikte auch kriege in dieser welt nur
beenden können wenn die europäer und die
amerikaner hand in hand arbeiten und das
ist in den letzten jahren deutlicher
weise nicht immer der fall gewesen und
das muss anders werden
herzlichen dank herr außenminister
zunächst mal wünschen wir ihnen dass sie
gesund bleiben und wenn das ergebnis
dann feststeht werden wir noch mal
versuchen durch zu klingeln
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei der schau dich je das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren